i remember working at barnes noble and
my favorite was to have a hilarious
interaction with people and i remember i
took this one i almost got fired i took
this woman up to she was looking for
a magazine
and i was and
i took her up uh on the escalator it was
an aster place barnes nobody took her up
and i started walking towards the
magazines and i forgot she was with me
and and i was thinking to myself i was
like i don't like this job like i don't
like working here and i forgot she was
with me and i started walking to the
cafe to go get a coffee
and she all of a sudden we're in line at
the cafe and she's like
is this where the magazines are and i
was like oh oh i'm sorry
she goes wait did you forget you were i
was with you and i and i just said my
head's just not in this and she was like
what i was like i don't think i can take
you to the magazine
she was like wait hold on and i told her
i said i don't want to work here and she
was like she's like this isn't my
problem and i said no i think it is now
because i think you've got to find that
magazine on your own
so i'll have a
sit on the toilet for a while yeah don't
come with me yeah she just and she was
like i'm gonna tell your manager and i
was like you can i'm trying to get fired
and then i just went i ended up getting
fired for working out in the basement my
underwear a lot worse
yeah i worked in astra plays barnes and
noble i met my first gay dude like legit
gay dude he had just come out of the
closet from like nebraska and he moved
no one accepted in his hometown and he
moved to new york and he when i met him
he said
our boss duane at the time said uh
everyone tell us what you do tell us
what you do and i said i'm and i was the
first one to go i'm bert i'm a stand-up
community he goes no you work at barnes
and noble what are you doing guys like
i'm a musician he goes no you work at
barnes and noble and then he got to him
and he goes what do you do and he goes
i'm gay he goes okay you're gay so he
goes around but then me and him work the
information desk and i said you're gay
and he said yeah and i said i don't
really know any gay people and he said
uh me either i said what he goes that's
why i came to new york i don't i didn't
know any gay people no one was gay where
i was from so he's like i'm here so i
watched him like come out of the closet
was the coolest thing he's like he
[ __ ] a lot like and he'd come home
every morning he'd come back to work
with a new story like a crazy wild
adventure he was on and so we would take
the freight elevator down to the bottom
and we would light a joint and we'd once
you had the freight elevator no one
could come in on you right so we take it
down to the basement without a joint and
he told me his stories like one time he
came in with a black eye and he goes i
got [ __ ] out of my loft last night and
i was like for real and he was like dude
it was crazy you know how good sex got
to be to get back into a loft get [ __ ]
out again i was like and so we would sit
that and then
i realized i was going using that for
the there and i was i was like i wonder
if i could come down here and work out
like you know take a little break from
work go down to the basement do push-ups
do sit-ups with a gay guy no no just by
myself because once you took it down no
one could come in on you no one could
find you no one can see what you're
doing right so i go down and this is a
little side bar the aster place barn
zone oval had no air conditioning right
none right so if i would have to take
off all my clothes i wouldn't want to
get them sweaty right work out right
dry off
and then put my clothes back on
towels paper towels paper towels and or
just sit there for a little bit and
relax
put all my clothes back on go back up
and just go back to work have a coffee
eat diet fuel was big then if you'll
have like six of those right be like
humming like a junkie right um and then
one day my my boss
uh brought me down
to the uh basement or to his office i
remember and he was like um
he was like hey you spend a lot of time
in the freight over or in the basement
aren't you i said well the travel books
are down there he's like you know we
have
cameras everywhere right i was like i
didn't know that and he was like oh
you're fired i was like i quit and he
went
great
and i walked out and then i walked out
and i walked out and a week later uh
will smith discovered me will smith
discover me and i got a development deal
and where did will smith see you uh his
people david talked about the guy who
worked for him uh discovered me at the
boston comedy club i did
an article called they don't see the
tape of you working out here no no
and so then i got to deal with will
smith i moved out here for seven months
lived at the universal sheridan
developing a sitcom and then i came back
to new york and i have money and i had
like i think i got a tv show and i went
back to new york and i went back to the
astor place figuring everyone knew i got
fired for working out in the basement in
my underwear
and i walked back up to the information
desk and the gay guy was there and he
was like um
he was like what's up
i was like nothing and he and he just we
went back to our i said he said uh our
manager got fired and i was like shut
the [ __ ] up and he's like guess what he
guess what he does for a living he
doesn't work at barnes noble
and he goes i'm still gay he goes guess
what happened last night and he
we didn't talk about me getting fired or
anything we talked about one of his
sexual expertise i didn't even tell him
that i had gotten a deal i didn't tell
you he still worked there i don't know i
really liked that guy that was i was a
cool guy
[Music]
you